these you just [ __ ] feel it and
oftentimes when I'm rushed in a in a
quick moment and a short Q&A or
fireside chat I come out guns a-blazing
they're just something about Baron Davis
is all-star weekend kind of moment that
brought out a real passion in my stomach
and this was the result I'm feeling
tremendous you know if you told me that
I was gonna introduce me on stage is
creator of brands father I'm an
entrepreneur I was born in Belarus and a
former Soviet Union came to the States
lived in a studio apartment in Queens
with seven family members I came from
[ __ ] from the gutter right I was also a
DNF student so in the 80s and 90s
education was the only way out to
entrepreneurship wasn't this thing that
it is now that we give a [ __ ] about and
so basically for the first 17 years of
my life I was told that I was losing
that I wasn't good and you know between
DNA and more importantly a all-time
mother and father you know I was in my
own head I thought I was good you know I
was making two three thousand dollars a
weekend so in baseball cards when I was
13 so I was struggling to understand why
is gonna be a [ __ ] loser and it just
made no sense right teachers are like
you're gonna suck I'm like I make more
money than you dick so you know
entrepreneurship wasn't that thing that
it is today
I was I was grinding my dad at that
point saved all his money bought a
liquor store made the American dream for
our family I went into that business and
over the first 12 years of my career
from 22 to 34
I built my dad's business for him had no
equity and it built my dad's business
for the 3 to a 60 million dollar
business and then I left you know and
started vaynermedia in between after
being right about EECOM about right
about email and Google I wasn't gonna
let it pass me by and when I saw the
next big thing that ended up being
social media so I was an early investor
in Twitter and Facebook and Tumblr
so I'm rich
I'll tell where it was but talking about
you know like when you were running your
desk this yeah right yeah and knowing
that you're an entrepreneur and you're
not running it for you so yeah like what
are the tools that you are to be able to
cast away or to leave something that you
grew it was interesting to hear Chris up
here talking about people thinking that
they can be athletes or be better at
basketball than him that's what I feel
is happening with entrepreneurship right
now right everybody's got entrepreneur
in their Instagram profile but there's a
big [ __ ] difference between being a
successful entrepreneur and being one I
see a lot of people who play
so so you know for me for me it was the
work right like you know I see my man
dunk here like he's putting in the work
at he's a youngster he meets JJ look old
right like people there's a few that are
coming up that actually want the work
the way I thought about it was I gave up
all my 20s right your actions have to
match your ambitions right people are
talking a lot of [ __ ] but not putting in
the work here's my life from 22 to 30 I
lived in New Jersey I worked 15 hours a
day Monday through Saturday
I got rest on Sunday and saw my family I
never went out I didn't buy dumb [ __ ] to
make me look cool the girls and I
[ __ ] put in work and I got skills and
then I put him to use in my 30s and now
I'm 42
youngest [ __ ] I'm gonna buy the Jets
when seven Super Bowls and call it a day
[Applause]
but the reason and by the way I don't
think it's cool that I gave up all my
20s contrary I'm sad I get it like like
you know like I gave them up though
because I didn't want to be a hypocrite
I have big ambitions I want it and I
thought that was a time when I'd have
the most flexibility to put in all the
work that's anything great yeah right
this lose out you're gonna miss
something right to that point like at
the cross section that we are here
there's nobody that makes it into the
league without sacrificing Thanks
and and I think successful entrepreneurs
is the league there's nobody who's hit
it who did it who got lucky people love
lucky people love excuses you're in
control of your [ __ ] the Internet's
changed everything every excuse coming
out of your mouth the answer is and
because the Internet has changed
everything we haven't calibrated how big
it is there's no middleman
there's no system there's no old white
dude stop and you go do your thing
this internet thing is real as [ __ ] and
so for me I just think it's the greatest
time to be alive and if you're not
winning during this era of internet at
scale and [ __ ] nine straight years of
economic growth then you suck
I mean cuz look how many people under 30
raise your hands
right right tons of them so one of the
things I hate is that people [ __ ] on
Millennials they're lazy they're the
same way everybody's the same you knew
lazy people you need hard-working people
Oh
Millennials have so many advantages
under 30 has so many advantages they
actually the only disadvantage I think
they have is they haven't been punched
in the mouth yet right they haven't
lived through 2008 or 2001 there's a lot
of people in here over 40 who were rich
on paper or had made it in 2001 2006 and
then the economy got bucked right it's
real cool when you're an Instagram
influencer and making $100,000 in
sponsorship deals until the world melts
and those brands aren't paying so so my
big fear right now is like look be smart
be thoughtful like build something that
you can control like everybody crying
about Instagram and Facebook's algorithm
it was free
you built on it for free so they changed
it because the attention of that user is
everything that's what matters and so
they're gonna do it what's right for
them and so if you're crying that you're
organic reach dropped then [ __ ] work
startup [ __ ] podcast [ __ ] start a
newsletter like do something instead of
crying that you got 7,000 likes instead
of 11,000 [ __ ] loser
it's true it was three people like all
my shits [ __ ] up now I don't have as
much engagement I'm like it was free
what's real quick I know a lot of people
here don't know me I'm not trying to
hurt or be funny I'm trying to help you
never be never be at the mercy of
something you don't control and then
also you know I backstab well your
business has the capabilities where do
you see that
I'll be raising one thing what are you
doing and why are you here I'm here
because all of culture is here this
weekend right like LA and Bay All Star
is like you know I don't work on
weekends like I don't miss family time
on weekends because I work so hard but
this was just can't miss obviously
Boehner sports my brother AJ and I have
started a sports representation business
we think we're gonna disrupt it I can go
into that but I'm here because culture
is here cuz Chris's point is right the
MBA is done it's so right because the
faces are seen because they're not
debate baseball BAM made a lot of money
for the owners in the short term but in
the long term the three best players of
baseball can walk down this street right
now make it and nobody would give a [ __ ]
that's bad
I should say like physically I guess I
get it but but you know to answer your
question my number one objective right
now in general is to make good traits
alpha so what I'm real passionate about
right now is making empathy and
gratitude and kindness coolest [ __ ] what
because to the heart point that's the
most important thing right now we have a
very interesting time you know Chris
mentioned it this is what going on in my
life right
a fleet wannabe rappers rappers want to
be athletes and now everybody wants to
be an entrepreneur right and by the way
let me give you a headline this is only
gonna last five to seven years cuz when
[ __ ] melts and everybody has to get a
job they're gonna say [ __ ] that
entrepreneur [ __ ] so it's got a moment
they'll come back in 40 years but this
is the moment and while I'm sitting
where I'm sitting in that moment I'm
gonna try to do some good with it and
here's what's good doing the right thing
is always the right thing there's a lot
of people that don't understand how
business really works have leverage you
want to have leverage give more than you
take that's how you win
and these are just truths and then it
manifests in business I'm leaving real
[ __ ] economics on the table every
year because I'm gaining points leverage
leverage leverage get smart about who
you're doing that with then you can
build something very meaningful
[Music]
[Applause]